por aquí tenemos esta ecuación que está
muy interesante y vamos a ver si podemos
resolverla para acá y claro suponiendo
que m es más grande que 0 y como siempre
pausa el vídeo de si puedes resolverlo
por ti mismo y después lo voy a resolver
contigo ok vamos a trabajarlo la clave
de esto es simplificar estos exponentes
que tenemos aquí usando las propiedades
de los exponentes y bueno lo primero que
quiero es que observes la parte de la
fracción que está a la izquierda de la
ecuación m elevado a la potencia 7
novenos entre m elevado a la potencia un
tercio y la clave para resolverlo es
recordar que si tengo dejar ponerla por
aquí que si tengo x elevado a la
potencia a entre x elevado la potencia b
bueno pues sabemos que esto es lo mismo
que x elevado a la potencia a menos
y bueno es que esto realmente viene de
recordar la noción de que x elevado a la
am / x elevado a la b esto es
exactamente lo mismo que x elevado a la
que multiplica a 1 entre x elevado a la
b recuerdas y bueno esto es lo mismo que
tener x elevado a la que multiplica am y
bueno uno entre x a la vez es lo mismo
que x elevado a la menos ver estás de
acuerdo y bueno es que esto va a ser lo
mismo y recuerda si tengo una pase
elevado a un exponente por la misma base
elevada a otro exponente eso va a ser lo
mismo que la base elevada a la suma de
los exponentes estás de acuerdo en este
caso me quedaría a más menos b pero
bueno eso es lo mismo que a menos
así que llegamos al mismo lugar y por lo
tanto vamos a describir esto vamos a
reescribir esto de la siguiente manera
me va a quedar m elevado a las 7 novenos
menos un tercio está de acuerdo
siete novenos menos
versión y bueno eso va a ser igual esto
va a ser igual a m elevado a la cae
entre 9 elevado a la k entre 9 y ahora
sí cuánto es 7 novenos menos un tercio
bueno si buscamos un común denominador
vamos a ver que esto es lo mismo que
tomarme m a las siete novenos menos y un
tercio un tercio es lo mismo que bueno
tres novenos estás de acuerdo esto es lo
mismo que tres novenos y ahora sí ya
tenemos un denominador común y va a ser
muy fácil restar esto esto es igual a m
elevado a la cam entre 9 y creo que ya
ves a dónde vamos porque esto sí yo lo
simplificó que me va a quedar esto me va
a quedar como m m elevado a las 7 no
menos menos 39 nos eso es lo mismo que 4
no menos 4 novenos y eso va a ser igual
va a ser igual a m elevado a la k entre
9 y ya está porque esto nos está
diciendo que 4 novenos tiene que ser
igual acá entre 9 déjame ponerlo keane
49 nos tiene que ser igual a camps entre
9 k entre 9 y esto me está diciendo que
acá tiene que ser igual a 4 y ya está lo
hemos logrado